rainbow six siege is a
wonderful game it demands skill and
creativity
it's it's great but sometimes
it just sucks from ddosing
to cheaters to getting shot through god
damn bullet holes siege can be the most
frustrating game in the world and yet we
keep
playing it we love it but we also kind
of hate it
so to celebrate our weird twisted
relationship with siege
let's talk about the things that piss us
off the most about the game
here are the top 10 things you hate
in rainbow six siege
kicking off our list at the number 10
spot is the thing that
all players no matter what rank hate
the god damn maps no
no no
oh no look most siege maps are fine but
when you're playing ranked and you end
up
on outback all you want to do is
vomit look at this dude we're [ __ ]
hopping we're hopping straight in
we're hopping straight in from the
oregon rework to
outback fantastic luckily ubisoft is
about to give fans
some much needed control over what maps
they play
but for years they were stuck with the
game's
many horrible maps that's super easy
skyscraper
that map's [ __ ] garbage you put me on
the record though i don't even care i'll
say that anyway i literally tweeted out
like almost weekly [ __ ] skyscraper that
sucks [ __ ] get rid of hereford it's
the worst map in the game
the community has begged ubisoft to just
make the map pool the same in ranked and
competitive and even though progress has
been made you still might have to suffer
through canal
i think that canal is one of the worst
maps in the entire game of siege they've
reworked it
it was a good idea but they have to end
it at that they just have to remove it
coming in at number nine are one
youtuber's disciples
and their infuriating strats
in the bomb chassis oh my god dude this
guy's just a [ __ ]
rat have you ever been stuck in a lobby
playing against
someone obsessed with rat strats the
kind of players who don't actually care
about
winning they just want to do something
wacky and frustrating to make you
look bad
that is the craziest [ __ ] i've ever seen
pulse has like a [ __ ] rat hole he's
going to have
popular youtuber coconut raw is the
patron
saint of these rats and his dark twisted
mind
is what comes up with the kinds of
strats that make you feel like
the biggest [ __ ] in the world this
right here is a precise grenade bounce
that bounces off the top of a reinforced
wall
i know i'm doing this with buck we could
also do this with sledge maybe get a
friend to open it up for you
this is the big brain yellow mine setup
on canal
once they run past and detonate this
from the drone hole they're actually
going to be too far from the window to
turn around due to the concussion
effects of the grizma mine
i knew of multiple ways to do it i
didn't think
it was like crate that special though i
went into a custom game i was like oh
yeah that way doesn't work
but then there's like a couple others
that i knew about
at number eight is an issue that has
been plaguing rainbow six for
years ddos attacks
he just put it in a maximum overdrive
are you sure now that it's just a
coincidence
no no no i was pretty sure before i'm
just saying we can't counter
region is is
imagine being one round away from
winning the game you've done
everything right and then all of a
sudden the game
crashes you get no elo for winning no
rewards
nothing you just lost 50 minutes of your
life all because of one
salty [ __ ] and his ddosing and even
when the game doesn't crash
you have to deal with [ __ ] like
is going to this mo that looks so dope
i can't even shoot i can't do that yeah
they just get stressed so there's the
towel
i'm just standing still there's no point
in moving
look at those stones oh they actually
hit him
coming in at number seven is mouse and
keyboard players
on console i feel sorry for all the
casual guys i'm
gonna be [ __ ] on basically because
i'm a smurf using an m k in casual
versing low levels please forgive me i'm
going to destroy my mouse and key right
after this video
now most people play siege on console
which means
most people who play siege use a
controller that's totally fine
but everyone knows it's just not as
accurate as using a mouse and keyboard
securing the container all right this is
this is bad i feel like a dick
the problem is when someone plugs their
mouse and keyboard
into their console they become unto a
god
smashing controller plebs and their
inferior devices with their own
superior aiming skills except they
aren't actually more skilled they just
plugged in a better controller
it's hard to imagine anything more
unfair than this
just so you know you're cheating you're
like you know what are you streaming do
you accept that at least or no
actually no i'm not is there a bomb
look shield operators shields are
uninteractive
and basically fly in the face of fps
design all of a sudden
you're not aiming and firing you have to
stop and deal with this
stupid undamageable rock that's sitting
on site
[Music]
that's crazy that this is just working
for them so well like how do you how do
you how do you beat it
how do you beat the botsy plant on this
like what you supposed to do i don't get
it now you can definitely deal with them
it's not that hard but no one likes
doing it
and yet ubisoft has continued to put new
shield ops in the game
giving us some of the most hilarious and
infuriating moments
siege has ever seen
what the [ __ ] is it
coming in at the halfway point on our
list are client-sided bodies
what is that
left side left side now although it
doesn't seem like the corpses of your
defeated enemies would be a big deal
it turns out that every dead body and
siege is positioned specifically for
your client
that means every single ragdolling
corpse is in a different place for
every single player on the server
what i want to see this oh you can't
kill cab chris
okay this is my last game and if that
doesn't seem like a big deal
well you should know that it can lead to
some very awkward and
unfortunate situations
i i cannot see you there's a body in the
way
oh my god i got this kind of like 10
health too
let's let's watch this [ __ ] beautiful
kill cam as this guy shoots me
straight through a [ __ ] quiet side
body
in rainbow six there's one thing that
every team needs which is why the number
four spot on our list is
those times when your team just doesn't
pick a hard reacher
[Music]
raise your hand if this has happened to
you you're loading into the game
and you realize that you don't see a
single hard breach operator on your team
no hibana no thermite not even
an ace thankfully ubisoft has finally
added a hard
breaching secondary gadget siege which
means your useless
fuse main can finally feel good about
himself and get a
[ __ ] wall open
for our number three spot we have the
dreaded rainbow six siege
sound engine
that made no noise him opening that up
made absolutely
no noise is the audio in this game
broken
here's one that cs go fans might relate
to see rainbow six is notorious for
having a sound engine that just
sucks of course
bro of course bro where am i hearing you
guys from
all right i can't go off sound from
weird audio glitches
to trying to figure out where an
opponent is the sound engine in rainbow
six siege
just can't hold up luckily ubisoft is
working on
fixing the sound engine and have already
made a ton
of progress
[Music]
yeah let's go let's go
coming in at the runner-up spot on our
list is the smallest
but scummiest part of siege bullet holes
i've got white stairs we can tell you
i actually outplayed her with my you
know 12 000 game time i calculated the
angle here
rainbow six is a pretty well designed
game with fantastic destructibility
but sometimes you have to wonder if
there's such a thing
as too much destructibility the first
method from nico is by doing a double
smack to get through the desk while
being safe and sound on the other side
if you want to you can also add a few
extra melee holes on the south side
because then if an attacker does see you
he's gonna have to get really lucky on
which one to pre-fire
bullet holes are small but they're
deadly giving you a line of sight that
almost
no one else could expect definitely not
the way you want to get knocked out of a
round
taking the top spot on our list is of
course
the bane of every fps cheaters
oh god i don't even know what i died
from obviously died
yeah i did too he knew exactly where i
was
now although cheaters are everywhere
it's particularly bad in rainbow six you
see
siege doesn't have third-party servers
with more powerful anti-cheat software
fans are stuck with battle eye and
well it's not great that dude is
blatantly [ __ ] cheating
okay there he is holy [ __ ] is he [ __ ]
moving
he wasn't even moving dude
i can tell man
okay the timing was perfect dude
unfortunately unless ubi takes the
initiative to implement a more intrusive
anti-cheat system
ranked will just keep getting overrun by
dirty
filthy cheaters um for the people that
got gifted subs
from simply earlier all right that's our
list
now i want you to take that seething
siege rage and
let it go use it for something
productive like subscribing to our
youtube channel
turning on notifications liking this
video and leaving a comment
there don't you feel better now like my
dream is to get paid in peripherals no
my actual dream is to get paid to cs go
skins
but one my girlfriend would leave me two
it's never gonna happen it's just never
gonna happen like
no but it's like i would the funny thing
is like people laugh and like like at
first glance you'd be like no of course
like pay this idiot and [ __ ] cs go
skins but i would want like a
significant you know what i mean like
i want like a four thousand dollar
dragon lore